let's go next to adrian
from san francisco california
hello hello david can you hear me i
can't and you are
you're not calling in from san francisco
argentina right you're san francisco
california
i didn't even know there was one in
argentina many people didn't know today
many people don't hey david i wanted to
ask you about what are your thoughts on
you know having us troops in the middle
east seeing there have been a recent
delay in removing troops from
afghanistan i'm asking because
there's one hypothesis where you know
troops are necessary to stabilize the
area and prevent insurgencies
but i'm really curious to see if you
think we even have an obligation
in the first place seeing the cost of
american lives and capital
yeah so we've been talking about this
really uh for almost two full decades
that that's the right i mean
the question fundamentally is that of
responsibility
if we cause a problem in the middle east
how long do we have a responsibility to
stay
for so-called peacekeeping purposes
and stabilization purposes i have no
clue
i don't know what the answer is and you
know we're we're in
some of these countries because of
decisions made multiple presidents ago
by george w bush
does but where does joe biden's
responsibility
go for the destabilization that george w
bush
bush's decisions brought to the middle
east i do not know what the answer is
i think that at a certain point you can
make the case
that if you say ahead of time to the
world community
and to everyone involved we
understand our role in creating the
situation
that was many presidents ago and much
foreign policy ago
we are announcing that every troop will
be gone by x date
let's work together to figure out how to
make that a real reality but the u.s is
getting out period
and then you you figure out what to do i
would think that that is that is at some
point has to be morally acceptable
but your question of if you broke it how
long do you have a responsibility to
continue fixing it as a good one
and i don't know what the answer is you
know david you make a really interesting
parallel to uh
reparations uh the case for reparations
by to nihi coates because
it's the same philosophical question of
if we broke something
in this case the horrible institution of
shadow slavery right now
how long does it have to take until we
have to uh you know morally have the
obligation or responsibility to
well i think that one is a little
different and more complicated for
for a few reasons one is that there's a
question
as to whether if you just throw money at
individuals on the basis that they are
still
affected by the way the system
used to work you're arguably ignoring
elements of the system today that still
don't actually work correctly
and and some folks believe that the
first step has to be to actually reform
institutions
rather than than financial reparation i
mean this is a bigger topic
it's a different topic than the one
maybe you're bringing up but i think
that it's
it's even more complicated arguably yeah
it certainly is
hey david i am a first time brand new
listener to your show so
keep it up all right thank you so much
appreciate the call very important
good substantive questions love it